[Music]
we are back 8:14 with Carson and Hoda's
exclusive let me point something out mhm
Carson Daly left his Late
Show for Lily Singh to take it and now
Carson Dy has a better job now because
regardless this this is a better
paycheck this is a better paycheck this
is a better paycheck for sure
interview with Jada pinket Smith and
everyone's going to be talking about
this yeah she is one half of Hollywood's
most powerful couple she's at the center
of constant gossip and controversy
including that slap of the Oscar she was
sitting right next
to I would hate the no this studio the
set the couch thing I would hate this
would you not want oh yeah it's the
worst like sitting all together on a c
like and then like the table's not close
enough like Carson D I'm just watching
him he's all awkward cuz he's further
away from the table he didn't know what
to do with his legs like I hate this
apparently Carson Dy now also hosts a
voice too he's got a couple gigs of
those are Easy Money gigs you know what
it was man they got Lily sing on some
social justice [__] they wanted to make
a buzz with the woke Zoomer crowd and
they probably bumped Carson and they
went look we we'll work with you man cuz
he's like the new Jay Leno or like the
new ronc Crest where he's just a company
man yeah so they were like look you'll
land on your feet buddy just don't make
any noise and he was probably like okay
man wherever you need me and then they
were like you know what give him some
gigs he's generic enough and when we met
up with Jada in our hometown of
Baltimore to talk about her candid new
Memoir worthy she opened up about an
issue that has been kept secret until
now this woman man even the title of her
book it's everything about her is just
she's a
[__] there are so many surprising things
in the book but the thing that surprised
me the most that I actually Fu Tupac I
didn't know that I I on the book to
reread it was that when he was in the
Digital Underground or before the
Digital
Underground she also [__] shock CH oh
well he the one that put the satin on
your
panties because I said is this true
right was that in
2016 you and will decided that you were
going to live completely separate lives
it was not a divorce on paper but it was
a
divorce so then what was the slap
about I don't know he probably trying to
impress her get her back I don't [__]
know honestly you know what the slap was
about the slap was about the slap was
never about Jada the slap has always
been about will will went up and smack
Chris Rock because his pride was hurt
because his wife was hurting his pride
at home and even though he couldn't [__]
his wife anymore and he couldn't be with
his wife anymore they had to publicly be
together together and then every time
they started making fun of this [__]
the [__] reflects on him so now I got to
I can't even be with you but I got to
put up with this [__] so he smack Chris
Rock for Will Smith not for Jay yeah and
you know being separate being separated
that long um I get it you know that's
your private life but doesn't explain
why you you [__] your son's friend
it's a little weird right like that like
like okay fine whatever you haven't been
together 2016 why lie about it for so
long it's it's a weird thing also at the
way while this reporter's talking to her
she's definitely like first of all
Classic Hollywood just narcissist
sociopath crazy person but like she's on
[__] she's on Sam's on drugs everyone
you're on [__] drugs look at the CU
like the way she goes I found out from
the book in 2016 you and and the whole
time she's
going and it's like what are you doing
are you on the same planet right now
that is not how people talk to each
other no you're
2016 which is 7 years ago yeah farest
Mommy goes look I get why Will Smith
[__] Margot Robbie but why would you
[__] your son's friend yeah did he [__]
Mar nice good for him so why is he so
why is he going around like being such a
[__] like you should be feeling I I
don't know [__] this old bald [__]
y'all have
been apart
yeah but you see what I mean with the
smiling
in why are you smiling as you say
it she's she's a
sociopath but in public the couple who
married in
1997 denied the gossip about their so
you've been lying no you've been lying
which people wouldn't be so shocked
right people wouldn't be so
shocked if you in 2016 go hey you know
what we're going to get separated
doesn't matter what you did right but
the problem is you just kind of been
lying about it and then again the slap I
think now 100% mcha is right like he was
doing it for him like we all had our
theories that he was doing it for her
because that he was like are you going
to let him talk to me that way but it it
does it does kind of seem now like um
she worked him into a shoot and then
anytime like and then you know somebody
was goofing on her and he was like [__]
again I would be if I had to publicly be
associated with a woman and pretend that
we're a couple when we're not and I'm
not getting no [__] [__] out of it
and I'm not she's not clean in my house
she's not doing anything contributing to
my household Bo I got to go out in
public with her all the time and then
she starts going bald and everybody's
goofing on her and [__] I would have to
do something at that point I'd be so
[__] worked up I'd go I'd smack Chris
Rock in his mouth you [__] Margo
Robbie in her prime I don't care about
anything else at that point see but if
you had that context I wouldn't be
smacking anybody yeah it's a good point
I believe it's
fine their marriage this interview on
Bravo Watch what happened live with Andy
Cohen was taped a year after Will and
Jada separated so how long have you guys
been together uh 23 years wow that's
amazing hot oh this is that CNN Guy the
one that they told couldn't do New
Year's Eve anymore cuz he got really
weird remember the one that was re got
drunk and weird and yeah I didn't know
they told him he couldn't do it anymore
that's kind of funny um how do I keep it
hot uh uh [__] my son's friend most
pretty hot most that keeps it pretty
excess and it's weird cuz this is 2017
so he's
no uh maybe I I don't
[Laughter]
know wow you went you went you you
poured through the footage for that I'm
baffled really right over the next
several years Jada and will kept up the
appearance of a committed married couple
they even faced a scandal when Jada had
what she called an entangle hold on a
second we got some we we we we got some
things here that a a little [__]
weird before that entanglement with her
son's friend and all that
stuff she was it's it's not that 2016
and they kept it private we played the
clips on this show when she was trying
to monetize her
marriage with with that red table talks
and then she was doing Facebook videos
and he was like leave me alone that's
what I was bringing up well no she was
doing that to promote the the stupid
thing when it was launching but she was
like videotaping him in the kitchen and
he's like and pretending like they're
still together like this whole more
sense why he was annoyed cuz he's like
so you're using me for clout but you
don't want me in the house right and so
he was in the house he was cooking or
something if I remember correctly that
video and and and and like she was just
bothering him and he goes look I have my
brand and brand and blah blah blah blah
blah and she cuz the literal video that
video was him saying you know this is
how how we make it work you know being
married for this long and that was like
2 3 years
ago it was definitely after 2016 yeah no
it was um if I had to guess that was
around 2019 20 yeah it was pre-co so it
was like
yeah when Jada had what she called an
entanglement with a family friend
neither let the public know they had
already did you like how they said with
a family friend
instead of with her son's friend because
that is a big difference right yeah by
the way that I love that this has become
the quintessential Will Smith picture
now yeah this is like the meme picture
now the sad Will
Smith ready split so I guess my question
is I feel like you're a straight talker
I am then why have you been lying since
2016 yeah why don't you lie for years m
except you're not sometimes yeah so why
do you're a straight talker what does
that except you're not sometimes well
what does that mean this is this is that
[__] media Hollywood double talken
women are stupid it's like semi-ironic
Bros no but this isn't just Hollywood
this is a female thing where it's like
they they they they'll justify their own
shitty they'll rationalize shitty
actions and they say things like you're
a real straight shooter except m is the
most honest guy I know except when I'm
not except he's a pathological liar wait
what but that's what you're doing right
like you can't be both I never lie
except just then mhm do that like what
was the reason I think just not being
ready yet ready for what for what ma'
you're in your 50s still trying to
figure out between the two of us ma'am
you now look like
Cisco so honestly we're a little ready
what are you ready for true Hil to
forgive you for doing the Wild Wild West
soundtrack yeah how to be in
Partnership right and in regards to how
do we present that to people you know
and we hadn't figured that out during
our walk in bore ino in the chat says
ma'am it is not ALU when you just keep
cutting your hair shorter and shorter
yeah Jada reflected on their breakup
why did the relationship
fra well mostly because I was [__] my
son's friend didn't help so she TR
transitioning to to one of those studs
now for real dude sure oh why Frac that
that's a lot of things yeah why does she
here's another question I have about her
why does she still talk Hood when she's
been out of the hood for a really long
time she doesn't she changed she's she's
a chameleon she's just doing it right
now she wasn't even doing it in the in
the interview she she's outside in
bodymore murderland yeah she's out there
in bore baby so she's like yo yo so dead
ass B said R 2016 dog you talking about
by the time we got to 2016 we were just
exhausted with trying I think we were
both kind of still stuck in our fantasy
of what we thought the other person
should be J said like for
example you he was a super successful
actor and you weren't and he thought man
she's really leeching on me I wish she'd
be nicer and you were like no I also
deserve this Fame because I was in The
Matrix Reloaded and uh uh uh what was
what else what else was she in I'm
really trying to think I'm not I'm not
I'm I'm I'm really trying to think what
else it off okay okay what else
um
uh I she was in a lot of black woman
movies mhm she wasn't more from Living
Single right no you're thinking of uh
Kad
okay got it yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah as she considered a legal divorce
but problem is I can't tell '90s
actresses apart they all look the same
to me could never go through with it I
made a promise that there she was in
Gotham she was in Gotham the young
Batman show I think yeah she was in that
the young Batman show yeah yeah Batman
Jr little little Batman little Batman
little
Batman will never be a reason
for us to get a that go made no sense to
me I'm like wait so Bruce Wayne's like 8
years old and these people are all in
their 40s what he's going to fight them
when they're in their 60s Tupac Tupac
was in
her that is
true whatever and I just haven't been
able that's what it was and We've joked
about it before but it Bears repeating
you [__] Tupac and now you have to [__]
Will Smith I don't need to rap in my
albums
Smith I get it to break that
promise look at that face look I'm just
pausing what is this you know what it
looks like when what's her face play
Michelle Obama right before she says it
you co
you Viola Davis God man that's my one of
my favorite clips of all
time I'm I'm pulling it up I have to
have it pulled up at all times and it's
my fault for not for not do but I always
have have the uron video and one day I
had to take a [__] really John Edwards
have Secret Service what about John
McCain Mitt Romney probably not yeah you
know
why you're a [__] you're a
[__] there it is look at
that that's that's that's Michelle obot
Every Time I Ever Saw Michelle Obama
speak publicly I was like that's her oh
ghetto ass this is the worst [__] the
worst
caricature you know what's weird is
Viola Davis is actually a good actress
so like what is this about you know I
don't know I love that they post that
clip proudly to this like this is a good
clip that was a great it's a powerful
scene but you still live separately we
live
separately I have smiles when you say
that yes our marriage failed M
yeah so do I I have so many questions
just why why can I ask raspy voiced guy
why why do you have so many questions I
only have one question who
cares Al Roker apparently I it was a
strangest kind of
Revelation yeah man no [__] way on
the left yeah that's what he looks like
now I mean I knew he got skinny and like
he was one of those guys that got weird
looking when he got skinny yeah too but
he's had like work done too or something
he looks like old like an old black man
but he's too smooth yeah like he's too
like he looks like an unrendered turtle
in a video game mhm it looks like
somebody took a A fine grain sandpaper
to him right it looks like you're always
looking at him from far away
yes of Revelation to realize Force
perspective face yeah it's it's uh all
the uh polygons haven't loaded yet yeah
they haven't yeah yeah is that these two
people have had Separate Lives I mean
they have not called each other husband
and wife in all of those years yes they
did we we saw them do it on that video
from before what are you [__] talking
about except for the appearance
everywhere they went except for the
appearances right are you a little old
for leather pants including at the
Oscars yes by the way there's a whole
Chunk in this book that we're going to
get into in the DAT Line special and
also a little later here of what
happened in that moment when he said can
you that's what I want to see where's
that you know get my wife's name out of
your mouth that kind of thing that's not
what he said what he said was how chunky
Carson daily going to get before they
sell him something I was actually going
to just I was going to I was like I
don't know what Roy point is he he's
about to make but as soon as he's done
I'm going to bring up how chunky Carson
is in here you can see it right yeah
he's getting a little which by the way
good for him take that money bro eat a
little bit who cares your young Days Are
Over you already [__] Jennifer Love hu
in her prime you know what I mean
honestly and yo get an extra bourbon
with your steak you [__] Britney
Murphy when she wasn't on that much
drugs he
didson [__] the women he [__] is crazy
look maybe not like a Britney Spears and
[__] but some of like the hot like be
listers that walked in through [__]
total requests you don't think he was
banging them and the fans and stuff too
oh yeah whenever like we [__] on
somebody and then people go you're just
jealous that they blank well I'm not the
jealous type if I I like you I root for
you Carson D is the epitome one of those
guys were you're like good for you bro
like there's no jealousy here at all
guy's not talented in particularly
talented or good at anything he's just a
generic pour me into a suit host king of
all Yeti called him Carson daily Carson
daily there's a whole backstory there
too but Jada is candid and honest in
this book I mean she's saying things
that she's never said so they've kind of
been living she talking about [__]
her son's friend
a it's a family friend they refer to the
family though was her son yes pretend
life publicly for years they knew the
secret they know it so now she's telling
everyone but they're still they're not
divorced so they're separ don't plan on
it they don't plan on getting I think a
lot of American families can relate
though I think there's a lot more
distance between husbands and wives than
no anybody ever really talks about
yeah uh Carson is there some problems at
home
bud did you hear that line no what'd he
say listen listen book I mean she's
saying things that she's never said so
they've kind of been living this pretend
life publicly for years they knew the
secret they know so now she's telling
everyone but they're still they're not
divorced n so they're separ they don't
plan on it they don't plan on getting
divor I think a lot of American families
can relate though I think there's a lot
more distance between husbands and wives
than no anybody ever really talks about
yeah yeah everything I want all right
with you Carson you okay bud also why do
you sound like raspby voice black guy
too is it Carson okay I don't know does
he he probably also smokes like he's
probably smoking boozing and eating all
the time but this sounds like something
does not sound like him it sounds like
something more you sound like me dude go
it's a bigger Delta we have a lot more
on on this conversation I was fascinated
by her by the way first time I'd sat
down and spoke with her for a long
period of time we read the book I read
the book from cover to cover yeah we're
going to do a special on NBC News it's
called Jada story Friday night 8 also
why y'all freeezing my boy cars that
daily out too does that feel like
they're kind of freezing him out he's a
newbie yeah but Jesus Christ give him
give him a little something back I want
to hear your podcast with can go like
two hours long for let's go Carson all
right let wow you're right you could
call they're really just [__] cutting
them out it's so interesting because I
mean how people are going to react
because it's one thing I mean everyone
understands a marriage breaking up or
you know things being complicated with
your family also do Katie kurick and Al
Roker not like each other because why
are they sitting so far apart I don't
think anybody on that set actually likes
each other that kind of ruse is you know
I know you ask her a lot about that yeah
there'll be a lot lot more and weer
alive is he awake he hasn't said a word
he has anything that also spoke to
people magine I want to get that job I
want to be at NBC for so [__] long
that they put me on the prime show in
the morning pay me good because you know
they're paying Roker oh yeah yeah yeah
bu you don't you don't they don't take
money away every year you know what I
mean they give you money more money
every year so he's been around the NBC
building as long as the [__] you know
the equipment that's in the building and
he dude I want the job where you just
sit there in the morning and do
this